oh I do like a party one babe what
should happen if you forget about me
Simeone fair
oh never forget about you pay a promise
evil and I'm a hundred top we should be
working this weekend Robin but I
promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you won't be coming to the cottage well
it can't be helped your life is
happening now right in front of you what
to do what to do what to do what to do
indeed oh poor Christopher Robin hello
the tree I remember was in the
countryside not here in London the sir
opening
I suppose it's where it needs to be
let's a silly explanation wash thank you
who why are you here oh yes I need your
help
I've lost all of my friends let's get to
the bottom of this look up here I come
it would appear that I am stuck have you
do stateand honey I have not just eating
dirty I wonder which way I always get to
where I'm going by walking way from
where I have been no you that's the way
I go
whatever your Christopher Robert its you
played it's gonna see if identified
piglets I've already stayed far too long
hello everyone so nice to see you all
again
why shake your silly old bear I was
wrong about work I was wrong about
everything and I've got to get back to
my family
farewell Christopher Robin I would have
liked it to go on for a while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
[Music]
you must bring Matalin wait he all the
bear of my father's Florence yes do you
know where he is I did I just thought oh
sweet bus tourism
[Music]
piglet if anyone wants to clap now is
the time to do it I don't remember being
cheery people say nothing is impossible
but I do nothing every day
no poo that's not
[Music]
you